tell me about this because now when
you're an independent now yeah
so what does that say that to me it says
that you think the republican party
is unsavable unsavable oh no doubt about
it
because otherwise you would want to stay
on right and reform it
but you think it's it can't be saved it
cannot be saved
yeah i mean you know it's it's the
craziest thing in the world because
again talking about us and when i first
came here
i remember you were the only guy that
would actually defend conservatives
somebody
attacked me on my first show here i
think um
called me a bigot and a racist because i
was a republican from the south a
conservative
uh and you defended me and
it's always very nice you know somebody
defending somebody because they're
conservative
i used to get attacked by liberals
because i was a conservative now i'm
getting attacked
by people who voted for a fascist
because i'm a conservative and that's
you know my friends and my family
members
they all voted for him and it's
it's been hard for me to sort of process
it
but the only way i i've been able to
come to terms with it is you know
they're not fascists
but they voted for an ignorant man who
is a fascist
i don't understand why i've seen focus
groups over the past couple days
of trump voters who still would support
him
who say things like i like donald trump
because of where he stands i can't even
say with a straight face
on the issues now you tell me what the
[ __ ] does that mean
what what what does he what
issues but what what issues
what issues does this guy share
with conservatives his biggest he left
with the biggest
assets ever the biggest debt ever he
undercut all of our
allies all of all the allies that reagan
championed he he embraced russia
but he's gone joe no no why are we still
talking about
cause 70 5 million people
and i've got to say all of my people
my tribe they voted for him so when when
i see these focus groups i feel like
it's that
you'll remember this movie because you
remember chico marx there was this late
60s movie called
journey to the other side of the sun
yeah where everybody looked the same
but everything was opposite and so when
i see focus groups
with trump supporters i'm like yeah
that's they all voted for me
and the strangest things come out of
their mouths
you